aux événements extraordinaires
pendant plusieurs jours au delà janvier
ou le kazakhstan a subi une crise
d'échelle et qui devenu le plus sérieux
depuis les trente ans de souveraineté de
la dépendance et même notre organisation
a jamais fait face à cette menace
j'aimerais remercier notre président du
conseil de sécurité et messieurs nicolas
pas chiante pour un travail accéléré
dans le but est de faire valider les
documents nécessaires et surtout
j'aimerais remercier messieurs vladimir
poutine pour
la compréhension et la résolution rapide
concernant l'envoi des troupes de la p2
le tc au kazakhstan cher monsieur
vladimir poutine nous avons toujours
tenu la communication directe depuis le
premier jour de l'attaqué terroriste
contre notre pays et maintenant
j'aimerais remercier alexandre
lukashenko et messieurs je pars aubin et
messieurs mali rakhmon
pour la fraternité politique et de
combat aujourd'hui nous avons le 2
nationales liées
aux victimes au kazakhstan et j'aimerais
vous remercier pour les condoléances et
et j'aimerais
faire part de ma gratitude à messieurs
stanislav as le ses côtés général de
l'hôtel pour les efforts communs de
notre organisation est donc au
secrétariat en fait c'est le cas où le
potentiel de la p2 le tc a été
réellement activée dans le but d'assurer
la sécurité la stabilité et l'intégrité
de long est des pays participants à le
thé c'est pour nous
tout d'abord c'est le soutien politique
et morale de nos partenaires dans le
courant de l'été c est surtout très
important parce que tous les états
participants ont soutenu la déclaration
la demande d'un kazakhstan maintenant
j'aimerais vous informer sur la
situation actuelle dans notre pays et
pour vous dire ce qui s'est passé depuis
les derniers jours art maîtrisons
l'image est complétée de l'association
je peux vous déclare officiellement que
tous les événements depuis le début de
l'année en cours représente les jalons
d'une seule chaîne
et qui représente en fait
le complot
destructeur il lié à une préparation qui
a duré et non deux ans trois ans c'est
la même question qui va donner
l'information parce qu'il y avait des
tentatives elle
d'initier le désordre
dans le pays pour menacer la stabilité
et l'intégrité du pays et toutes ces
actions ont été
supprimés avec une détermination
mais quand même cette impréparation des
attaques
mais les deux combats ont
continué et ils
s'étaient liés au mécontentement de la
population à cause de la hausse des prix
de du gaz
pour les automobiles est à toutes les
demandes des mécontents ont été entendus
par l'état le
gouvernement a
quitté ses fonctions et nous avons pris
des mesures économiques et avec un plan
exact des réformes politiques
mais pour les organisateurs de
l'agression contre le kazakhstan n'avait
pas d'importance parce que en continuant
à les mécontentements une vague
de désordre
massive a été initié comme date depuis
et selon un endroit unique et les
groupes radicaux avec des éléments
criminels
les bandits et d'autres délits car on a
paru et les exigences politiques et
sociales
commencé à
passer en deuxième et troisième à un
plan et maintenant nous avons vu
apparaître des groupes de terroristes
et pour nous la but principal est devenu
évident ceal la dissolution et la prise
du pouvoir avec la destruction du
pouvoir parce qu'il s'agit d'une
tentative d'un coup d'état est
maintenant pour nous il est évident que
tous ses activités militaires ont été
coordonnées de pions seul centre de
combat et maintenant les activités sont
passés en phase active et cela est
témoignée par des attaques est
synchronisé contre les bâtiments contre
les services de maintien de la paix et
contre les banquiers les objets
stratégiques et les écoles et les
chaînes de télévision avec des attaques
contre les aéroports et les chemins de
fer avec des routes ont été bloquées et
le fonctionnement des sapeurs pompiers
et des ambulances ont été bloqués aussi
surtout avec des attaques contre des
unités militaires ou les bandes ont
essayé de
de prendre les armes en particulier il y
avait un combat
aux alentours
du département où le bâtiment du
département de l'intérieur a dans la
ville alma tas qui a duré de nuitées et
les policiers ont été essayés à de
repousser les attaques
des terroristes
juste à alma-ata sept magasins
d'armes ont été pris il s'agit d
attaques avec des tireurs d'élite et les
touristes ont
utilisez les uniformes des militaires en
se protégeant du façon cynique et des
participants des désordres politiques
qui en lisent lié à on lisait les armes
contre bouclier
vivant en faisons des attaques contre
les policiers ou non
il ya deux soldats ont été décapités les
attaques barbares contre les hôpitaux
ont été aussi continuer et les bandits
on
déployer le front le plus
large possible en particulier en dans 11
régions mais surtout à le cours
principaux a été fait à contrôler mata
qu'on vous connaissez c'est le centre
qui conte du pays qui concentre les
noeuds de communication de transport et
surtout hall
le chute de cette ville aurait pu ouvrir
aux attaques contre tout le pays les
terroristes ont essayé
d'initier les attaques contre les forces
et les services de maintien de l'ordre
public et nous avons vu une
concentration des attaquants des
touristes autour de la résidence du
président du pis en fait c'était une
vraie guerre terroriste initiée contre
notre était un par des méthodes tout à
fait différente et ça nous a demandé de
prendre les mesures extraordinaires où
elle les forces de maintien de l'ordre
public kazakh ont pu prendre le contrôle
de la situation mais nous avons payé le
prix
très élevé avec des victimes parce qu'on
ne t'a les seize personnes
membres des services de maintien de
l'ordre public ont perdu leur vie avec
des victimes dans parmi la population
civile en se maintenant de préciser les
nombreux exact en environ 1300 sujet à
des milieux d'affaires ont sont devenus
victimes les véhicules et policiers au
total ont été brûlés aux alentours de
500 véhicules
nous avons vraiment d endommagement
matériel dont les et chez sont estimés
par la commission des terres et on nous
avons pu constater la participation des
théories des étrangers dans ces attaques
et c'est pas par hasard que les les
attaquants ont attaqué les morgues la
nuit en essayant de prendre les corps de
leurs oeufs les gars en fait c'était une
vraie fête des terroristes est
extrêmement bien connu en essayant de
cacher leurs traces et nous voyons
l'apparition du zoo de ekahau avec une
prise du pouvoir ultérieurement et suite
à la décision du conseil de sécurité
kazakhes basé sur l'estimation
multilatérales avec l'analyse des forces
de maintien de la paix ces attaques ont
été
considéré comme les attaques contre le
pouvoir et l'état et al matin es9
centres régionaux ont été pris à part
les bandits nous avons déclaré le mode
de l'opération antiterroriste et le
kazakhstan a demandé à le tc d'assurer
le soutien qui diminue vraiment au
portant et après avoir pris hélas pas la
venue de trois arguant de transport dans
la capitale de pis en eau a permis
d'envoyer les forces supplémentaires al
mata pour protéger la ville contre les
terroristes et actuellement suite à la
décision du conseil de sécurité dans la
capitale kazakh nous avons déployé il
nous avons initié et le fonctionnement
des troupes de la paix de le tester à
raison de 2000 et 300 personnes avec 301
véhicules et qui assurent la protection
de l'aéroport des dépôts militaires et
d'autres objets stratégique un peu plus
tard nous allons entendre
le rapport officiel du secrétaire
général doté c est sur la situation
actuelle comme j'ai déjà des ja
mentionné c'est la première opération de
maintien de la paix et dans inspirons
que les troupes vont acquérir une
expérience utile avec la mise à jour des
documents qui régissent les activités
mais quand même je peux vous confirmer
que le tc a démontré son utilité
parce qu'ils reposent en un mini-canif
de stabilité et de la sécurité de nos
états membres en fait les activités qui
se sont déroulées devenu jalon crucial
dans le développement de notre
organisation qui est maintenant
considéré comme institut international
sérieux parce que le kazakhstan vraiment
fait face à aux menaces communes contre
tous les états membres de le tester et
où le kazakhstan va faire sa
contribution est l'une des
recommandations
éventuel pourrait devenir la mise à jour
et la correction des délais de réaction
dans situations de crise et surtout où
ça nécessite la validation par les états
membres et et d'autres départements de
le tester surtout en ce qui concerne la
prise de décision sur l'utilisation des
soldats de la paix de le tester avec la
participation d'autres organisations et
d'autres médias internationaux leaders
aussi bien que de centre analytique de
différents pays nous voyons déjà qu'il y
à des questions concernant l'apparition
d'un soldat de la paix au kazakhstan qui
ressurgissent ses skis lié à
l'incompréhension de ce qui se passe au
pied où les médias étrangers
l'interprétation est incorrect de la
situation aussi bien que la lecture
intégrale de la situation politique
actuelle malgré tout les fêtes fournier
certaines sources d'information
disait qu'il s'agit d attaques contre
les manifestants et ce qui est vraiment
représente une désinformation noah n'ont
jamais utilisé les forces militaires
contre les manifestants et en sachant ce
fait les terroristes ont initié
plusieurs vague d'agressions
comme j'ai déjà dit pendant la première
étape les
manifestations civiles pacifiques contre
lui ensuite des démonstrations politique
et ce qui est a été constitué par les
attaques du la troisième vague et des
touristes qui ont agi initialement comme
les manifestants pacifiques et après
comme la tragédie dalmat taille qui va
qui sera décrit dans l'histoire à
passer qui il s'agit il s'agit d'une
défense individuelle ou d'auto défense
et collective de la ville en cas de l'
attaque externe est et dans les médias
après l'investigation préliminaire nous
allons fournir à l'agro de population
internationale les fêtes
concernant ces attaques terroristes
contre notre pays parce qu'actuellement
nous voyons certains institutions et
certains médias continuent à fournir les
informations incorrectes et qui ne se
base pas sur les fêtes vérifier j'espère
que les ambitions qu'on
leur réserve nations unies
l'organisation de shanghai le tc le cse
vont faire l'investigation
impartiale et des actions des
terroristes parce qu'il faut pas faire
des conclusions
préliminaires je remercie tous ceux qui
ont été mis sur depuis le début que
kazakhstan va franchir cette étape dure
dans notre histoire et je suis sûr que
grâce à nos efforts comment nous allons
faire de notre mieux pour que le
déploiement temporaire du potentiel et
pacifique de le tester soit le plus
efficace le plus sécurisé possible et je
dois dit directement que la mission des
troupes de la paix a été extrêmement
utile et
nécessaire
de notre part je pense que ce sera nous
sont non seulement le pour le kazakhstan
mais ce serait aussi utile pour tous les
états membres de le décès on ne peut pas
permettre le vide un terme à tiques pour
que ce soit pas rempli par ceux qui
fournissent des informations incorrectes
qui continue jusqu'à présent et vu
la décision qui a été prise et qui
prévoit le bepa bon du centre du haut
représentant aux
officiels et aux essais au kazakhstan
aura sa place si lyon i en espérant
avoir un dialogue pacifique avec eux la
grande population pour irradier lit et
faire face aux attaques terroristes
contre notre souveraineté nationale et
l'intégrité du territoire et je veux
vous assurer que le kazakhstan va
respecter strictement ses engagements
internationaux
chers collègues et cher ami actuellement
l'ordre constitutionnel au kazakhstan a
été restauré la menace à la sécurité du
pays ont-ils pu pallier dans le cadre le
perreux l'opération anti tourisme se
montrant d'un continuer les travaux
visant à identifier les terroristes est
jusqu'à actuellement nous avons déjà
identifié environ 10000 les personnes
nous sommes en train de vérifier et
d'investiguer leur appartenance au
groupe terroriste nous avons déjà
confisqué 116 unités d'armes et nous
comptions à identifier les terroristes
qui se cachent à nous du land de
nouveaux méthode en
mettant des uniformes et civile en se
hazan pour faire disparaître leurs
barbes et tous les institutions aux
politiques officielles et continuent
leur bon fonctionnement pour faire
revenir l'état a
en mode est de la vie normale et
maintenant je vais donner les nouvelles
missions à notre gouvernement
pour que l'opération antiterroriste à
deux grandes échelles soit finalisé avec
la mission efficace des troupes de la
paix de l'été c'est surtout le plus
important c'est de prévenir le retour
des saisies this situation ultérieure au
pire pour notre mission principale pour
les médias lequel instant et privat
toujours assuré a le soutien à ses
alliés merci beaucoup de votre attention